we've been getting going through
mechanics and what we're going to do is
we're going to push forward into
a really important topic one i've been
waiting for a long time to introduce
and it's best explained by well
some sports and so what i'm going to do
is make sure you've got your sound nice
and clear i'm going to
share a different screen through here
and show you a very very
brief video so enjoy
[Music]
if you look closely at this pack of
riders in the tour de france
you'll see some of the best cyclists in
the world they're here
in the back they're keeping up but also
resting
while their teammates in the front do
most of the work it's a technique called
drafting and it's what helps them
survive the three-week race around
france
but drafting only really makes a
difference on these parts of the route
the long flat and hilly stages here
cyclists ride together in a formation
called a peloton
it allows cyclists to save energy by
sitting behind another rider or drafting
at high speeds riders use most of their
energy to pedal against wind resistance
but when a rider stays close behind
another they're sheltered from much of
that
so pedaling becomes much easier and they
can keep up with the front riders
the way to measure this is to look at
how much power a cyclist generates
here at the front of the peloton a tour
de france rider will generate at least
300 watts of power
i jumped on a bike to see what that
feels like and just two kilometers
holding 300 watts was
really really hard by comparison
when a rider is behind the lead in the
peloton they only need to generate about
240 watts to move at the same speed
holding 240 watts for two kilometers
felt remarkably easier
so even though these two might finish a
200 kilometer flat stage at the same
time
one is going to be way less tired than
the other that's why you see some of the
tours best riders
here in the back they're drafting off
their teammates whose job it is to do
the hard work
now so that the team's best cyclist is
rested for the most difficult part
the mountains where they'll have to be
on their own
i i just couldn't help but take this
opportunity because some of you might
know if you're a cycling
fan that uh the tour de france is in its
final stages
now um and it just seemed so perfect to
me that that sport was going on even
though it's like it's once a year right
so it doesn't go around
i think it's like i don't know it's not
like 22 23 days or something like that
that it lasts but it happens to coincide
with when we are learning this very
particular part of
mechanics you guys know that so far
through all the different kinds of
motion that we've been looking at
we've more or less been ignoring the
medium that objects are passing
through whether that is air like you see
with the cyclists
or other media that actually push back
against whoever is trying to move
through the medium
you see this technique of drafting that
they explained in that video i wonder if
anyone knows
and you're looking to post it in the
chat another sport that makes a big deal
about this particularly when you're
doing longer distance
um i wonder if any of you actually did
this when you were younger yourselves i
know i had to because i had terrible
asthma
and i know mrs lee was actually also a
very good swimmer as well
um the whole principle of drafting works
anywhere
where the medium that you're trying to
move against is trying to move against
you or trying to push back
against you now this particular part of
mechanics maybe some of you guessed and
this is the time to make your heading if
you
would like to this part of mechanics is
called resisted
motion that's the heading you can make
the
usual the most frequent kind of
resistance comes from like i mentioned
the medium
you're traveling through and that might
be air or
water or maybe some particularly viscous
fluid
um that's not the only kind of
resistance that you can get
also you get resistance from things like
friction um which is sort of like a
subset of this if you like because when
you're going through a medium you're
just getting all this friction from
all the molecules and particles that
you're colliding with in the air
or the water so this idea of resisted
motion is uh really important to
consider
in situations like this we've been
ignoring it for a long time because
under most circumstances resistance can
be thought of as
negligible right it's so small that in
comparison to all the rest of the forces
that you're worrying about like say
the mass of an object or the force with
which it's projected out of a cannon or
something like that
air resistance might as well not be
there but
in and i said air resistance i said
resistance i should say resistance in
general
in situations like these resistance
makes a really big difference like
15 to 20 percent difference that is
enormous when it comes to whether you
win the race
or lose the race so that's why we're
going to look at resisted motion now
so what we're going to do in our time
together is have a look at this
example we're going to try and highlight
all of the bits of it that are
important and then there are also a few
questions in the exercise over
in canvas for you so you can have a look
at this question you don't need to write
down all of it as
is the case in many motion questions
there's a lot of detail
but we will highlight the important bits
that you should write down because
otherwise you can't solve the question
without them
now let's start at the top it says a
rowing eight
so you know eight guys eight girls in a
canoe or a kayak or something like that
they cross a finish line in a race with
speed five and a half meters
per second and then they stop rowing
okay so here's the situation
like i mentioned before with swimming um
the water that they are that this boat
is traveling through
is resisting their motion and that's why
i have to row hard to go up against it
in a greatly simplified mathematical
model the boat is slowed by two
drag forces so when they say drag
this is kind of one of the aerodynamic
words the physics words that indicates
to us
there is this resistance coming back
from the medium they're traveling
through
and then it highlights not that it
matters too much for our purposes two
things
skin drag and then later on it says form
drag and all that's meant by that is i
think the analogy that was given to me
once
is skin drag is the thing we're trying
to reduce by putting on a swimming cap
so if you put a swimming cap over a
swimmer's head and we've got some
swimming caps right here
you don't change the shape of the head
that you're swimming through the water
but what you do change is the actual
surface that's being that's going
through the water namely hair
versus this you know plastic latex that
kind of thing which is much smoother
so it would experience less skin drag so
less resistance
whereas you've also got form drag which
comes from as the question says
the shape of the boat pushing the water
aside
okay so what we've got is skin drag
form drag and then they provide to us
two expressions that represent
each of those respectively so here is
the expression
for skin drag and then i'm going to put
this one here in green this is the
expression for
form drag and those are pretty important
to write down i would write them
separately
to the equation that we're about to get
here thus
the force equation is all right now
there's a lot to unpack here let's see
what's going on
on the left hand side hopefully you
recognize this this is mass
times acceleration so m a that's force
so
maybe you want to just indicate that
that whole thing is force
and then what you've got is what colors
have i not used there we go
you've got this minus sign that comes
over here in the force equation what
does that indicate
it indicates that the two kinds of drag
skin drag for
form drag they're both slowing down
they're both reducing
the velocity making it go further and
further down to zero so this negative
indicates reduction or slowing
i might just say slowing
okay then if you have a look carefully
right you've got i'm going to look over
here on the left hand side first you've
got this mv
on a hundred so where does that come
from that's the form drag you can see
there so i'm going to highlight that
in green i think i've got a color for
that somewhere
there we go so there's the mv on a
hundred that's where that comes from
and then you've got this 1 over 10 mv
squared so if you
got the same denominator 1 over 100 then
you'd have a 10 up the top 10 over 100
so 10 mv squared and that m has already
been factorized out you can see there in
front of the brackets so that's why
this 10v squared is what you get from
the skin drag so
those two things are combined together
and they're both slowing us down
so that's why it's negative okay that is
the force equation
and x is given as the distance past the
finish line
so in some ways you could call this the
initial condition
even though the entire race has been
going but we're just interested in what
happens after you cross the finish line
so
x equals zero is the finish line and
then as x gets bigger you go further and
further along
then v is the speed of the boat all
right so what do we do with this well
firstly part a we want to find the
velocity as a function
of displacement v as a function of
x